[Music]
hey guys in this video we're going to
talk about Danny Targaryen faith in the
final season support with a few spoilers
leaks and of course theories and
predictions of mine let's take a look at
what Danny's row will look like in the
last six episodes curling Danny
accompanied with John is heading to
Winterfell with her all remaining
dragons and armies not to conquer it but
rather to save it from the night king
and his army of the dead Danny and John
are sailing towards by Harbor the main
seaport of Northland solid once they
arrive over daredevil me to track you on
the kingsroad and then write together to
Winterfell most of this will probably
take place of screen and you'll only see
them approaching and entering Winterfell
I assume this is an eighth official
photo is them looking at Manor fell from
a distance some believe this is
somewhere beyond the wall judging from
the landscape behind them but remember
winter is here and the net gains closer
to them than ever before so it could be
anywhere but my guess is it's somewhere
close to Winterfell this photo which was
released separately from the other
season 8 photos likely the pigs the same
scene between John and Danny but from a
different angle we've already known for
quite some time that John and Danny will
arrive at Winterfell in very first of
the final season in a callback to the
serious very first episode of the first
season with Daniel cam standing in for
King Robert and his so then he arrives
the Winterfell with John in the cruise
Jonathan introduces her to his family
and a photo ops is a tense meeting
between Danny and Sansa
but she first found out from the first
official game of Thrones season a teaser
posted by Entertainment Weekly
Entertainment Weekly always provided the
first exclusive look at what's to come
in the next season and this time was no
different they shared the entire season
8 cover story online when she closed a
detail description of the opening scene
there it says that sense I said not to
be thrilled that Jon Bettany to his new
fancy Targaryen girlfriend at least not
at first
and so what they meant by that when Game
of Thrones released a short clip of that
very meeting since it does save NFL is
your story's the same liner father said
to King Robert and here I demeanor fell
but by censors face expression we can
see she doesn't like any of that however
even though the post states that sense
is not real way John bending the knee to
Danny did you notice how it says senses
not thrilled
John Bethany to Danny or at least not at
first then is not heading north to
conquer the north but rather to save it
and that something the Norton Lords will
see for themselves in the very beginning
of the final season since they will
eventually see for yourself who Daniel
is and what her true intentions are and
without a doubt accept her as the
North's most trusted Ally and its only
hope
what full of snacks for Danny is an
urgent meeting a meaner fellow majority
of the North Lords and the North's
allies at the Great Hall in order to
discuss their strategy and offenses
against the knight King almost all the
main characters will be there which we
got to see from the first season eight
photos we got to see that was censored
Daniel Bryan but make no mistake almost
all main characters so the series will
be there as well
most likely including Jaime one of the
most important events of season
regarding the queen of dragons will
surely be your pregnancy in her eventual
marriage with Jon Snow while finding out
the truth about John's parentage is also
important highlight as one of the
season's biggest events with John Denny
brain and Sam being at the same place as
early as of season 8 premiere it's fair
to assume that either those two Sam or
brain will reveal the truth about Joshua
heritage to John and even possibly today
any too early on in the season obviously
this revelation of Danny being John's
and will come as a huge shock to both of
them and will most certainly change
their relationship therefore many of you
are probably wondering why would they
marry chatter upon finding out they're
in fact related I already made an entire
video regarding this topic but it's some
of you who have not seen it let me
introduce with a Targaryen varying
theory of mine with a few sentences yes
even though they will at this point be
aware of their family ties John and
Danny will marry in the fifth episode of
the final season but no they will not
marry just because of love or because
they want to seal their lines they will
do it because of their child John and
Danny might or might not continue their
intimate relationship after they found
out the truth but I don't have to
because Danny already got pregnant in
the season 7 finale and it might have
even been officially confirmed by an
actor who plays Jon Snow there's one
interview image the game turns
showrunners David and Dan are discussing
Danny's potential pregnancy with Kit
Harington an actor that portrays Jon
Snow it states Danny says that she
cannot have children and your life we'll
see about it on which one of the
showrunners left
regardless the scenery of the show's
next big twist their child was heavily
foreshadowed toward the previous season
multiple times
the Danish pregnancy almost became a
certain thing the most prominent one
would definitely be John doubting
Danny's believed that she cannot have
children
long story short even though both of
them will without a doubt refuse to even
think about marriage whether it's
political or Arab in the beginning of
the season upon learning that they're
related they'll hear even strong reasons
to do so later in the season and the
reason is going to be Danny's pregnancy
John has been a bastard son his entire
life and he most certainly will not
allow his child to be born out of
wedlock and live a life he's been living
Norwood Danny one that life for her
child both in the book series and on the
show Jen initially refuses to sleep with
a man because he's absolutely terrified
that he might produce a bastard and know
me how hard it's to grow up like that he
doesn't want to bring it up on any child
even when he falls in love it's great
it's hard for him to get over this fear
of intimacy that might lead to pregnancy
the fact that John himself is not
actually a bastard but a legitimate son
of Rhaegar Targaryen and Lyanna stark
insurer to the Iron Throne is highly
ironic of course but it doesn't change
the way he grew up and he most
definitely will not change his desire
not to bring another bastard named snow
into the world not only would it put
their child in a pretty bad situation
but House Targaryen could not be
continually they don't marry and make
the child legitimate so Targaryen
vetting is most likely happening later
on in the final season that's the only
way for their child to be legitimate to
be a Targaryen and the only way for
House Targaryen to not become extinct
after John and Danny's death now let's
see if Danny's rolling em turns might
end there are many possibilities from
her dying in childbirth to her becoming
denied screen
the most popular theory will definitely
be Danis sacrifice and death in order to
end along night both John and Danny are
tied to the other high prophecy which
includes a historic legend of a hero
sacrificing his love in order to save
the world from the long night now Sarge
already told Danny that she has a role
to play in the prophecy as does Jon Snow
then is wrong in the long night in this
theory would be her eventual sacrifice
and death it seems that just like azor
Ahai who had to drive his sword in his
wife's living heart in order to create
Lightbringer and the fee the White
Walkers general have to do the same
however while this theory almost
certainly met with Georgia Mars
announced Barriss attending I still
believe in a theory of mind that I
introduced with or a year ago will come
true and it's Danny becoming the night
screen the night screen is an unseen
woman in game
a legendary figure known in the Seven
Kingdoms and among the free folk
according to a legend the Lord Commander
of the Nights Watch found in a haunted
forest that called woman pit bright blue
eyes he took her to the other side of
the wall and declared himself as the
night's king their lawmen reign lasted
for 13 years whereupon the free folk
rallied under the banner of a
king-beyond-the-wall a march against the
nat king seat against the Nightfort
which resulted it night's king defeat
with an aide of House Stark earlier in
game external staff learned that the
leader the White Walkers night King is
able to create that White Walkers
but it seems that he can only create one
if that human being is a pure-blooded
incest born this means that the night's
king could turn Danny into one of them
since then is a pure-blooded instead
born daughter king garrison Queen
rhaella Targaryen the only way for the
living side went along now it is to
either defeat them which would be
insanely hard or to make a pact the
Specht of Ice and Fire would include
Danny have you ever wondered why is the
night king game and coming south
why was he preparing an army all those
years with which he started marching
south at the moment of Dana's arrival at
Westeros I was wondering about that ever
since the 60s and ended and I came to a
conclusion that Danny's arrival the
Westeros histories of the NAT Kings
preparations the reason of his march
south and his reason of every single
death that the Seven Kingdoms is going
to confront then he could have won the
throne as soon as she ride the Westeros
if she wanted to as john stated then he
did not take the throne yet only because
many ins the people would have died if
she decided to strong King's Landing
she did not attacking planning because
she did not want to cause death upon
millions of innocent people and she
won't ever sit on the Iron Throne
because she will decide to give her life
so those people including her child
could live then his visions are for
sharing the Danny could easily win the
Iron Throne and sit on it
but it also foreshadows that she will
realize that she will not be able to sit
on the same since she will have to give
up on it for the greater good she will
accept the pact with a knight King in
order to end the long night then he will
become the knight screen whereupon she
in a knight king will go beyond the wall
and all over it as a form of peace
agreement between the living and the
dead beside Danny's agents as I've
already said earlier in this video Danny
survival of Westeros satin at Kings
preparations that his march to the south
fits perfectly in timeline I don't think
it's coincidence that all those years 19
was preparing and gathering huge army
with which he started marching south at
the same time of Dana's arrival at
Ezra's also the fact that the
including multiple things that are
proving that Annette King can create
that why Walker stolen that human being
is a pure-blooded instance born has to
be for sharing something huge to that at
the fact that Danny's incest born
daughter of King Aerys and Queen rhaella
Targaryen and this theory has a huge
chance of coming true not only that this
theory would be one of the greatest
surprises the showrunners could pull out
but it would also fit perfectly with the
bittersweet ending that George armoire
announced Daniel in this theory died in
the hands of the night king as Danny and
will shortly after open arises the night
screen that's how I see the end of queen
of dragons I can see her dying in a
childbirth or John driving a sword in
her heart but I could see her
sacrificing your life for the greater
good just as every true Queen will do
for people there you have it guys then
it's faith in the final season support
of illegally photos official teasers and
of course some theories of mine and as
always I hope you guys enjoyed this
video if you did please make sure to
subscribe to our Channel and I hope to
see you in the next one peace
[Music]